[Music]
well we would also love to see you and
demi lovato get back together I would
love that too I'm doing a show with her
for the California State Fair in like
two weeks
oh really yeah so I'm gonna see her
actually I need to call her about that
because we have some together and we
should perform one together rats I'm
opening for her I'm her opening act
that's me
which is cool cuz I just I don't know I
love the idea of that because she's my
friend um how's she doing your tweet to
her was so sweet after everything she
was going through I know I had known
about it sure
I'm so close that's a close friend so I
had really wanted for her to be the one
to tell people that and I worried a lot
just as her friend that you know
something was gonna leak or somebody
would somehow like take that and use it
negatively against her or to make her
seem like she's got a secret you know um
so it was it's not my business to say to
your friend that you need to yeah but
it's your friend you know you worry and
you're like oh my god my friends she has
this thing that people could use against
her and I really want her to like right
and she did um and I didn't I didn't
know she was recording that song she
didn't tell me that so when I heard I
heard it when everybody else heard it
[Music]
on the floor I just was really proud of
her that she was honest because it's
really hard to be honest with yourself
so to be honest with the whole world
about something that you've struggled
with very publicly I think that it's
very admirable and I was very proud of
her to see her write that song in it and
put it out and to see everybody's
reception being so understanding of
where she's at I thought that was really
cool
[Music]